is Khloe Kardashian joining the cast of
Love is Blind not exactly but she is a
fan isn't that crazy the reality star
met season 2 Star Alexa Lemieux at an
event in Los Angeles for her clothing
line good American and posted about the
meeting on Instagram Coco called Alexa
you beautiful girl you and even added
that they look like twins we all want to
be cute over here okay but here's the
real kicker Coco suggested in the
caption I think some of us single K
sisters should go on Love is Blind what
do you think what do we think we would
love to see the Kardashians on the
Netflix series tune in because you never
know what's gonna happen Alexa commented
on closed Post writing wait did we just
become best friends adding that she
feels so grateful to have met such an
empowering woman we had fun always
learning how to spread love and
positivity
and Alexa she posted snap from the event
on Instagram too noting that people
compare her to Chloe IRL for all those
who call me a Chloe dupe just want to
say thank you for the compliment that's
when Coco slid into the comments writing
you're gorgeous what's your biggest turn
on
um you girl fans of the hit dating
series will recall Alexa met and married
her hubby Brandon Lemieux on the Netflix
show which is all about people meeting
each other and getting engaged sight
unseen you learn so much so you have
like an Awakening within yourself and
Brennan he was at the good American
event too he really is just the greatest
human being on Earth Alexis shared clips
from the night on Instagram writing
about the Public's fascination with her
Physique in the caption saying she looks
forward to the day women's bodies are no
longer a discussion and we can just be
who we are you have to truly love your
inner self before you can love the
outside all that sounds a whole lot like
Khloe I always want to evolve and grow
and mature emotionally
um because that's how we become better
people and while Alexa Found Love in the
pods there was never really a question
if we were gonna get married it was
always a yes there was never a question
in my mind mind things are a little more
complicated for Chloe following her
split from Tristan Thompson in 2021
they've been co-parenting the two
children they share together a
five-year-old daughter true and an
eight-month-old son whose name they have
yet to reveal he's named but I haven't
announced it you haven't announced it I
haven't announced it yet Azores recently
told ET that the NBA star still loves
Chloe would love to be with her again
and is doing whatever he can to try to
prove himself to his ex and her family
but the two are not together she chooses
to be supportive both publicly and
privately for the sake of their children
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style it's hard work for all parties
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
and while Coco might have been joking
about joining Love is Blind we hope she
finds her happily ever after whether
it's on screen or off
[Music]
thank you